these robots aren't building cars
they're assembling shoes here at amf
they're proud of their new equipment
it's helping them all out their latest
boot in cooperation with Michelin Amy fo
no sentiment we're not really feeling
the crisis we export ninety percent of
our products that's protected us he
found the Oghma Pharma no phone in the
last five or six years we've grown by
twenty-five percent per year since as a
knows I'm a estamos minutes while we
can't say we're caught up in the crisis
the crazy fate event amf produces work
shoes and is currently investing
millions to expand production and
retrain it's 80 employees Europe shoe
industry can't undercut cheap shoes
produced in Asia so manufacturers like
these are placing special emphasis on
quality our average price is the second
highest worldwide that's why you can't
call our shoes even take on some
ambitious shoes is also betting quality
will win over the international market
they export to 38 countries Japan is
their number two destination after
neighboring EU countries and demand for
their products is up fifty percent over
last year and CEO Hal Ramos wants the
next government to help keep his company
successful at kinkos padam regardless of
who is in charge I expect them to allow
us to keep working like we are they need
to help rebuild the economy and the
country and work to improve the economic
situation for everyone con ESO SI is
equal Uncas toads pechugas portugal shoe
industry employs around 40,000 and seems
to have walked off the worst of the
crisis the country's economy as a whole
is showing signs of improvement point
ein a couple of years ago Portuguese
exports were responsible for thirty
percent of profits now it's forty
percent and the trade deficit went from
six percent to almost zero but it's hard
to say if that's due to the current
government's policies ninety-five
percent of Portuguese shoe production is
destined for
it's a broad their products aren't in
demand at home some questions can we do
a query colorful shoes with more
creative designs most people here have
more traditional tastes e trow thing
would gather this you know but that may
change portugal is becoming a new
must-see destination for many tourists
and that's changing the look of
Portugal's big cities